[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit
Gundula Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend die Menschen sind wie
Dominosteine umgefallen berichtet eine
Augenzeuge in über die Massenpanik
gestern Abend in einem Ausgehviertel von
Seoul Südkorea die hämmernde Musik aus
Bars und Kneipen habe die Schreie der
Menge übertönt und so drängten immer
noch mehr feierungrige in die zu engen
Gassen des partyviertels was genau die
Panik auslöste ist unklar über 150 meist
sehr junge Leute erstickten oder wurden
totgetrampelt und viele Fragen sind noch
offen Miriam Steimer berichtet
die Straßen die so voll waren sind so
leer
in Soul trauern die Menschen um die
Opfer der Partynacht sie bringen nicht
nur Blumen sondern auch Getränke als
Geschenk für die Toten
die Erinnerung an Samstagnacht ist noch
ganz frisch
es war unmöglich herauszufinden was los
war alle waren in Panik
als wir herkamen auf dem Boden liegen
sehen wir wollten da nicht bleiben
wenn du Rettungskräfte siehst die
versuchen Leben zu retten und es nicht
schaffen das ist so hart
es sind diese Bilder die so schwer zu
ertragen sind
während sie auf der Straße versuchen
Menschenleben zu retten geht drinnen die
Party weiter viele hatten gar nicht
mitbekommen was passiert ist
mehr als 100.000 Leute waren in den
beliebten Ausgehviertel in der
südkoreanischen Hauptstadt das erste
große Halloween seit dem die
corona-regeln gelockert wurden in einer
engen Seitenstraße war es so voll dass
viele der mehr als 150 Opfer erdrückt
oder niedergetrampelt wurden vor allem
junge Frauen
wie genau ist zu der Massenpanik kam ist
noch unklar klar ist das Viertel war auf
den Ansturm nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet die Rettungskräfte kamen nur
schwer durch die vollgestopften Straßen
gerade jetzt nach Corona hätte man sich
eigentlich denken können dass es dann
halt eben noch voller ist als sonst und
ich denke da hätten wir dann schon
Rettungskräfte bereitstellen können bzw
den Bars Limits geben können an Leuten
die man halt eben rein und raus lässt
genau das verspricht der südkoreanische
Präsident nun aufzuklären er wolle
sicherstellen dass so etwas nie wieder
passiert
für sein Land rief er eine einwöchige
Staatstrauer aus
der Protest im Iran geht in die siebte
Woche und er hört nicht auf trotz
massiver Drohungen der Sicherheitskräfte
die Demonstranten sollten die Geduld des
Systems nicht überstrapazieren warte der
Kommandeur der einflussreichen
revolutionsgarten gestern wobei von
Geduld nach geschätzt mindestens 250
Toten und über 10.000 Festnahmen wohl
kaum die Rede sein kann die Sorge ist
dass die Bewahrer der islamischen
Revolution ab jetzt noch gewaltsamer
gegen die Demonstrierenden vorgehen
könnten Kamera und safarian berichtet
zusammen Stöße zwischen Studenten und
regimekräften heute an der Freien
Universität
Bilder die sich im Netz verbreiten immer
wieder auch Schüsse wie hier in Barney
im Kurdengebiet blutige Bilder auch aus
sorheda und im Südosten
hier schreien festgenommen um Hilfe
vergeblich die Vereinten Nationen
berichten von schweren
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
auf Partikel der Kennzahlen
Informationen das Sicherheitskräfte
verletzte Demonstranten von
Krankenhäusern in Gefängnisse
verschleppen den Familien werden die
Leichen ihrer getöteten Angehörigen
verweigert oder gesagt ihr bekommt sie
erst wenn es keine Beerdigung gibt und
nicht mit Medien geredet wird
Media sie war selbst über ein Jahr im
wien-gefängnis in Tehran inhaftiert
nergis ist candary Grünberg
Bürgermeisterin von Frankfurt gestern
auf einer Menschenkette für Iran in
Frankfurt sie fordert eine UN-Kommission
zur Aufklärung der Verbrechen im
Gottesstaat und das Ende der
Atomverhandlungen
brechen sie jegliche wirklich jegliche
diplomatische Beziehungen zu im Rahmen
ab keine Deal mehr ein Atom die mit
Verbrecher darf nicht stattfinden das
ist seit längerem gibt es keine
Gespräche daheim wir müssen deutlich
machen wir brauchen ein andere Regierung
im Iran wir brauchen andere Gespräche
und ich sage Ihnen wenn das ein
demokratischer Region im Iran geben
wurde wozu brauchen wir eine Atom die
weltweite Solidarität nicht nur in
Frankfurt sondern auch wie hier in
Israel
in Kanada läuft Regierungschef Justin
tridoo beim Protestmarsch mit
Solidarität auch bei der britischen Band
Coldplay sie spielt gemeinsam mit der
Schauspielerin Pfarrer horny den Song
der Protestbewegung barao
unbeeindruckt davon der Chef der
iranischen revolutionsgarten er
verkündet das Ende der Proteste lasst
die Böswilligkeiten beiseite die
Proteste sind hiermit zu Ende geht nicht
mehr auf die Straße
daraufhin sollen Sicherheitskräfte
landesweit mehr als 20 Universitäten
angegriffen haben um Proteste
einzudämmen wird an Eingreifen der
berüchtigten revolutionsgarten die
Proteste stoppen nein glaubt es kann da
die Grünberg
ständig
Menschen die Menschen wollen das nicht
auf Veränderung für eine bessere Welt
fahren in Normalität und die kann man
nicht mehr zurückdrehen und als ob sie
es gehört hätten reißen Studenten
weitere sollen des mularegimes ein die
Wände der Geschlechtertrennung in der
Mensa ihrer Universität
wie also geht es weiter im Iran und wie
soll Deutschland wie soll der Westen auf
die Proteste reagieren darüber wollen
wir reden mit dem deutsch-iranischen
Schriftsteller David Kermani guten Abend
nach Köln
guten Abend sie haben viele Kontakte in
den Iran in welcher Verfassung befindet
sich das Regime nach sechs Wochen
Protest könnte die Macht der Mullahs
Bröckel nach ihrer Einschätzung
sie bröckelt jedenfalls schon wir wissen
es gibt viele Gerüchte von
absatzbewegungen von familiendienst
Ausland gebracht werden ob das stimmt
das weiß ich nicht da mag auch
Wunschdenken dabei sein aber was wir
sehen ist dass dieser Protest jetzt in
die siebte Woche geht trotz aller Gewalt
trotz des Schießbefehls trotz aller
Ankündigungen jetzt sei es endgültig
vorbei die Gäste gefeiert nicht die
erste und dennoch geht es immer weiter
und ich möchte es vielleicht mit den
Worten einer ehemaligen
Parlamentsabgeordneten sagen die er
selbst eigentlich zum System gehört
dieser Geist ist nicht mehr in die
Flasche zurück zu bekommen aber klar ist
auch das ist keine Sache von eins zwei
drei vier Wochen das ist wird womöglich
lange dauern es ist ein waffenstarrendes
System es hat eine Reihe viele
gewaltbereite Anhänger die ihr Leben
oder jedenfalls ihr ihre Zukunft zu
verlieren haben und es ist nicht mehr
möglich gleichzeitig mit mit 10.000
100.000 protestieren die Proteste
verstreuen sich ist es ähnlich möchte
man das Beispiel nennen des Kampf gegen
die Apartheid hier haben wir ja auch
eine geschlechterappartheit der hat auch
Jahre gedauert und diese Beharrlichkeit
im Inneren und der Druck von außen der
Politik aber auch der
Zivilgesellschaften von außen der hat
dazu geführt dass die Apartheid zu Ende
ging und der wird womöglich auch dazu
führen nur ein solcher Druck kann
womöglich dazu führen dass auch dieses
Regime endlich verschwindet Stichwort
Druck von außen diese Koalition ist ja
angetreten mit dem Ziel eine
feministische eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik zu machen wie bewerten Sie
die bisherige Reaktion der
Bundesregierung
ich frag mal zurück Frau gelenik welcher
Druck wir haben zuerst ein langes
Schweigen gehabt als Proteste als schon
auf Menschen geschossen worden ist auf
insbesondere Frauen dann sagt die
Außenministerin das habe ja gar nicht
mit dem Islam zu tun und dann wurde
unter lauter Getöse lauten getöte
Sanktionen beschlossen die aber rein
symbolisch sind und unser Bundeskanzler
hat bis auf einen einzigen vollkommen
nichtssagenden tweet In diesen 6-7
Wochen kann ein einziges öffentliches
Wort gesagt zu den Protesten das fällt
auch im internationalen Vergleich auf
nicht Partei zu ergreifen wenn jemand
auf den anderen schießt das ist eine Art
von Partei Name und zwar für den der
schießt der Bundeskanzler mit ihnen die
Bundesregierung vor allem der
Bundeskanzler ergreift mit seinem
Schweigen Partei in diesem Konflikt das
muss ihm das muss uns bewusst sein wir
sind jetzt sozusagen eine Boot mit
Russland mit China mit mit Syrien ich
sehe diese Parteien Name leider nicht
dafür hat der Bundeskanzlerin so
deutlich sagen zu müssen das muss ihnen
nicht leid tun wir sind hier an einem
freien Land der außenpolit der Sprecher
der SPD Nils Schmidt hat dafür
gesprochen und der hat dazu aufgerufen
dass atomabkommen am atomabkommen
festzuhalten ist das Realpolitik oder
ein strategischer Fehler
es ist eine realpolitische Fehler denn
das atomabkommen zielt ja für das hier
übrigens damals das beschlossen wurde
war viele Menschen im Iran fanden das
gut sie haben sich gefreut aber wir
haben vollkommen veränderte
Rahmenbedingungen vollkommen veränderte
Situation und es ist keine Realpolitik
auf diese vollkommen veränderte
Situation nicht zu reagieren die zu
ignorieren ein solches Abkommen Bedarf
Stabilität die Hoffnung ist ja auch mit
diesem Abkommen dass man
Handelsbeziehungen öffnen kann dass man
das an die Gasabkommen an die
Gasvorkommen im Iran drankommt aber
Handel braucht Stabilität denn Abkommen
dort auch Legitimationen Mindestmaß an
Legitimation und eine ein System das so
offen von seiner Bevölkerung an
praktisch überall im Latten Frage
gestellt wird dass auf seine Menschen
schießen lässt auf Jugendliche schießen
lässt auf Frauen ein solches Regime kann
kein Verhandlungspartner sein und jedes
Abkommen das ist dann irgendwann gäbe
ich kann mir die Bilder gar nicht
ausmalen wie dann so einen Abkommen
gefeiert würde aber ein solches Abkommen
wird auch kein bestand haben weil es für
den eigenen Menschen abgelehnt wird aber
das atomabkommen zielte ja nicht in
erster Linie darauf die Gasvorkommen im
Iran auszubeuten sondern darauf dass die
Atombombe nicht in die Hände des
müller-regimes fällt ist das nicht ein
wichtiges Ziel an dem man festhalten
sollte
wie gesagt das Ziel ist war richtig aus
atomabkommen hatte zu seiner Zeit seine
Richtigkeit das war ein wesentliches
Ziel nur jetzt ist Iran sowieso schon
sehr sehr nah dran eine atomabkommen und
ist bietet Kalle keinerlei Gewehr das
ist es hat sich jetzt man sieht es ja
und der Ukraine dieses System bietet
keinerlei Gewehr dafür dass Sie sich an
das atomabkommen hält insofern ist es
zwar ein löbliches Ziel aber das Ziel
wird in diesem atomabkommen nicht
erreicht und ich muss doch drauf
bestehen das ist so dass das
atomabkommen natürlich das kann man auch
wirklich überall nachlesen das
atomabkommen natürlich auch
Handelsbeziehungen führt wir Deutschland
insbesondere ist dabei seine
Energiequellen zu diversifizieren das
kann man verstehen nach dem Desaster mit
Russland nur Steuern wird das nächste
Desaster zu indem wir wieder ein
kurzfristiges energiepolitisches Ziel
voranstellen und dabei übersehen dass
mit diesem Ziel uns überhaupt nicht
gedient ist weil wir das diesen Ziel gar
nicht näher kommen weil der
Verhandlungspartner nicht der ist den
wir uns wünschen
david camani war das mit einer
Einschätzung zu dem zu den Verhandlungen
über das atomabkommen die jetzt
ausgesetzt werden sollten vielen Dank
für das Gespräch und einen guten Abend
nach Köln
und wir machen hier weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula und die beginnen
mit den Folgen der Aufkündigung des
Getreide Deals
Russlands Stopp des getreideabkommens
mit der Ukraine hat international Kritik
ausgelöst die USA die EU und die NATO
forderten Moskau auf sich weiter anders
abkommen vom Sommer zu halten
Außenministerin baerbock erklärte
Millionen Menschen weltweit litten an
Hunger und seien auf die
Getreidelieferungen angewiesen die
Vereinten Nationen und die Türkei wollen
sich für eine Fortführung des Abkommens
einsetzen man stehe mit Russland in
Kontakt
in der Ukraine dauern die Angriffe an
vor allem die der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte auf die russisch besetzten
und annektierten Gebiete als
Voraussetzung für Verhandlungen mit
russland fordert die Ukraine die
sofortige Beendigung des Krieges und den
vollständigen Abzug der russischen
Streitkräfte von ukrainischem Gebiet so
reagierte das Außenministerium in Kiew
auf Russlands Außenminister lavroff der
ein Verhandlungsangebot von Präsident
Putin bekräftigt hatte
in Somalias Hauptstadt Mogadischu ist
die Zahl der Todesopfer bei den
schwersten Terroranschlägen seit Jahren
dort auf mindestens 100 gestiegen etwa
300 Menschen wurden verletzt als zwei
Autobomben gezündet von
Selbstmordattentätern kurz nacheinander
vor dem Bildungsministerium explodierten
die islamistische terrormiliz Al Shabab
bekannte sich zu der Tat die meisten
Opfer sind laut Polizei Zivilisten
befürchtet wird dass die Zahl der Toten
noch steigt
und beim Einsturz einer Brücke beim
morbi im Westen von Indien sind
mindestens 68 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen nach einer Renovierung war die
Hängebrücke aus dem 19 Jahrhundert erst
vor kurzem wieder geöffnet worden
offenbar hielt sie der Belastung nicht
stand nach örtlichen Angaben stürzten
bis zu 300 Menschen in den darunter
fließenden Fluss
das Bürgergeld mit höheren Regelsätzen
und weniger Sanktionen soll ab Januar
Hartz IV ablösen nun droht die Union das
geplante Gesetz im Bundesrat zu
blockieren
CDU-Generalsekretär Czaja kritisierte
der Entwurf setzte falsche Anreize etwa
durch den höheren Vermögensfreibetrag
Landkreise und Jobcenter warnen vor
einer Überforderung der Behörden wegen
des großen administrativen Aufwands die
SPD verteidigte das Bürgergeld als
größte Sozialreform seit Jahren die
Sicherheit in der Krise gebe und hofft
auf einen Start im Januar
in Brasilien ist heute Stichwahl der
rechtsextreme Amtsinhaber ja hier
bolsonaro kam im nationalfarben-shirt
zur Stimmabgabe sein Herausforderer und
linken Ikone Lula der Silva macht es
selfies mit Unterstützern der Wahlkampf
der hinter ihnen liegt war brutal beide
Kontrahenten warfen sich gegenseitig
alle möglichen Verbrechen vor von
Kannibalismus bis zur Teufelsanbetung
Präsident bolsonaro suchte dabei ganz
bewusst die Nähe der erzkonservativen
Evangelikalen die bis zu einem Drittel
der brasilianischen Welle ausmachen weil
sonaro inszeniert sich also als Erlöser
sein Kontrahent sei der Antichrist
Christoph rückerath berichtet über das
Kopf an Kopf Rennen bei dem beiden
Kandidaten nichts heilig ist
du sollst keine anderen Götter neben mir
haben steht in der Bibel doch wenn
Präsident bolzenaru in diese mega-kirche
in Rio kommt ist ihm Anbetung sicher die
mächtigsten Evangelikalen Brasiliens
stehen an seiner Seite
starpastor sie das malafaya macht offen
Wahlkampf für ihn
[Musik]
im Namen Jesu wir stimmen überein dass
die korrupten die Ausbeuter der Nation
nicht mehr zurück an die Macht dürfen
gemeint ist bolzenarus gegen Kandidat
Ex-Präsident Lula das Silva in dessen
Amtszeit ein beispielloser
korruptions-skandal viel aber auch viele
Verbesserungen für die Armen und um
deren Stimmen geht es jetzt mehr denn je
die evangelikalen Kirchen sind ja
Schlüssel zu den Armenvierteln denn sie
sind präsent und helfen wo der Staat
versagt doch das hat seinen Preis
sie geben den Armen Selbstwertgefühl
aber sie nutzen das wirtschaftlich und
politisch um ihre Macht auszubauen
im Kulturkampf der diese Wahl prägt sind
bolzenare und ein Großteil der
evangelikalen natürliche Verbündete sie
propagieren ein erzkonservatives Welt
und Familienbild zumindest nach außen es
war bolzenarus dritte Ehefrau Michelle
die den katholischen bolzenaru zu den
evangelikal
ihr Pastor ist Jojo valando für ihn
besteht kein Zweifel welcher Kandidat
für Gottes Willen steht und wer dagegen
jemand der Christ ist Gott liebt die
Bibel liest und sie unterstützt der bei
gleichzeitig für Abtreibung ist
drogenpredigt gender Ideologie ich weiß
nicht ob der ein Christ ist ein echter
Christ würde hier in Brasilien niemals
für die Linke Stimmen
gender Ideologie Abtreibung
kampfbegriffe des bolsonaro-lagers
designen Gegner Lula deformieren sollen
vieles davon ist übertrieben oder falsch
und schafft es dennoch in die Predigten
der Pastoren und so sucht auch Lula
verstärkt die Nähe der evangelikalen er
sei nicht für Abtreibung und würde schon
gar nicht die Kirchen schließen sagt er
immer wieder der Antichrist sei wenn
überhaupt Präsident bolsonaro seine
extrem rechte Politik predige
Ausgrenzung und Hass sagt er mit Lula
Verbündete Pastor Enrique wie jeder das
Evangelium ist mit der Logik des
bolzenarismus und vereinbar es ist eine
Botschaft des Lebens der Liebe des
Friedens der Gemeinschaft
arbeitet mit Hass Gewalt Rache der
Ermutigung zum Waffengebrauch ja fast
einer Feier des Todes
die Linken Evangelikalen sind in der
Minderheit und auch sie kämpfen um die
Stimmen der Gläubigen denn jede Stimme
zählt in diesem engen Rennen um die
Macht in Brasilien
und das Wahlergebnis aus Brasilien soll
es heute Nacht gehen und jetzt kommen
wir zu einem Stück Hoffnung der deutsche
Umweltpreis den der Bundespräsident
heute in Magdeburg verlieh ist eine Art
optimistenprämie für Tüftler
Ingenieurinnen und Forscher die sich
nicht damit abfinden wollen dass der
Klimawandel am Ende siegen und unsere
Welt zerstören wird Sven Rieken erzählt
uns die Geschichte zweier Daniel
Düsentriebs deren Erfindung die
Schifffahrt auf klimakurs bringen könnte
Containerriesen fahren in Hamburg mitten
rein in die Stadt was oben aus den
Schornsteinen kommt wird selten so
deutlich sichtbar wie hier rund 3% der
weltweiten CO2-Emissionen stammen von
Schiffen eine Milliarde Tonnen jährlich
du Kleemann wollte das ändern doch der
Schiffsausrüster hatte es schwer
es war nie so dass in der Schifffahrt
jemand danach gefragt hätte kannst du
mir CO2 sparen das änderte sich als in
einer norwegischen Reederei eine neue
die junge Generation dran kam und die
sich zum Ziel setzen den sie einen
Reederei die nicht so viele Schiffe
hatten zu sagen wir möchten ganz gerne
in den nächsten drei Jahren 30 Prozent
CO2 sparen die zündende Idee hatte
Friedrich Mewes er kombinierte zwei
bewährte Systeme durch die von ihm
entwickelte Düse kann die
Schiffsschraube dahinter mehr Wasser
bewegen also bei gleicher Drehzahl mehr
Kraft entfalten außerdem gibt es weniger
Verwirbelungen die ansonsten Energie
fressen
irgendwann habe ich überlegt das du
kannst wirklich nichts Neues erfinden
das gibt es Meister gibt schon hundert
Jahre und dann ist war irgendwann der
Gedanke na ja dann musst du mal gucken
dann musst Du vielleicht kannst Du zwei
mehrere Sachen zusammenstecken
tatsächlich erreichte die Kombination
aus Wasserdüse und finde bis zu 10%
Kraftstoff Ersparnis im Modell würden
sich diese Werte bei echten Schiffen
wiederholen wäre das ein großer Erfolg
und dann wurde es zweistellig in den
Prozenten dass die Schiffe besser wurden
also weit mehr als 10%. und habe ich
denn gesagt hey das ist doch
unrealistisch wenn wenn das so wäre dann
gibt es das doch schon lange tatsächlich
gab es diese Idee noch nicht wohl auch
deshalb weil die von Mewes entwickelte
Düse direkt vor der Schiffsschraube
liegt würde die beschädigt der Schaden
ginge in die Million mein Kollege Dirk
Lehmann ich habe dann mein Vater bist du
eigentlich versichert gegen den Schaden
nee ich bin überzeugt dass es hält
Pferde hat sich nicht versichert also es
ist schon
großes Maß an Überzeugung inzwischen
haben die Werften weltweit rund 1800
Schiffe mit dem Bäcker mewesdakt
Englisch für Düse ausgestattet macht
annähernd 13 Millionen Tonnen
eingespartes Kohlendioxid seit 2009 die
etablierten Reedereien haben der
Sparpotenzial erkannt
es gibt aber auch jeder rein die sich
noch nicht so drum Scheren die wird man
auch nie dazu bekommen schwarze Schafe
gibt's überall und umwelttechnisch
gesehen stimmt ja schwarze Schaf sogar
leider und ja das sieht man dann auch
die Idee von Friedrich Mewes kann rein
technisch gesehen bei rund 5000 Schiffen
der weltweiten Handelsflotte eingesetzt
werden das wären dann noch mal und eine
Millionen Tonnen CO2 weniger jedes Jahr
und hier geht es jetzt noch mal weiter
mit Gundula und Meldungen zunächst vom
Sport da gab es heute drei Spiele in der
Fußball-Bundesliga Union Berlin hat
Bayern München wieder von der
Tabellenspitze verdrängt mit dem 2:1
Sieg über Borussia Mönchengladbach
Schalke 04 verlor gegen den SC Freiburg
0:2 Freiburg damit auf Platz drei der
Tabelle und das Spiel 1 fC Köln gegen
TSG Hoffenheim ging unentschieden aus
eins zu eins in der
Frauenfußball-Bundesliga hat
Titelverteidiger VfL Wolfsburg die
Führung ausgebaut die Wölfin in gewannen
bei Werder Bremen 3:2 zuvor hatten sich
die Fußballerinnen von Bayern München
gegen den SV Meppen durchgesetzt klarer
Bühl erzielte das erste von insgesamt
drei Toren für Bayern München entstand
drei zu eins
mehr flüde Gensch hatte bei dem
rassistischen Anschlag 1993 in Solingen
fünf Familienmitglieder verloren jetzt
ist die Friedensbotschafterin im Alter
von 79 Jahren gestorben NRW
Ministerpräsident wüst würdigte sie als
großes Vorbild der Versöhnung am 29 mai
1993 hatten vier Neonazis ihr Haus
angezündet und ihre zwei Töchter zwei
Enkelinnen und eine Nichte getötet so
wie 17 Familienmitglieder schwer
verletzt unmittelbar danach und seither
engagierte sich mit lüdegensch für
Versöhnung und interkulturellen Dialog
vielfach wurde sie dafür gewürdigt
heute traf es den Riesen Dino im
Berliner Naturkundemuseum zwei
AktivistInnen der radikalen klimagruppe
letzte Generation klebten sich an den
Haltestangen des dinosaurierskeletts
fest die Polizei löste sie wieder ab und
nahm sie fest seit Wochen sorgen die
Aktivisten für Aufregung mal kleben Sie
Ihre Handflächen auf die Berliner
Stadtautobahn mal bewerfen sie
weltberühmte Gemälde mit Kartoffelbrei
oder Tomatensuppe das Ziel ist klar
Aufmerksamkeit für die Umweltzerstörung
zu erregen die Frage ist aber dürfen die
das und was ist wichtiger die Kunst oder
die Weltrettung Christa Läpple mit der
Suche nach Antworten
Berlin an diesem Sonntagnachmittag die
Schlange zur Museumsinsel ist noch
länger als sonst üblich aus gegebenen
Anlass sind die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
verschärft worden ab jetzt heißt es für
jeden es müssen alle Taschen und alle
Jacken abgegeben werden ausnahmslos
das ist der Grund europaweit klimaaktion
gegen die Kunst laut starke Proteste um
die Welt zu retten wie es heißt
Monets heuschhuber Handelswert 111
Millionen Euro geschützt dem Potsdamer
Museum Barberini nur durch eine
Glasscheibe aber wozu die Anschläge
Menschen
Mensch frieren Menschen sterben wir sind
in einer Klimakatastrophe ich verstehe
die Sorge ich verstehe auch die
Verzweiflung aber bitte attackieren an
der richtigen Stelle
Aufmerksamkeit ist alles es geht um die
Bilder für die Nachrichten jüngstes
Beispiel am vergangenen Freitag vermehrt
Mädchen mit dem glasperlenring in den
hach diesmal Tomatensuppe per Twitter
millionenfach geteilt zu sehen sind zwei
Aktivisten und ein unschlüssiger
Wachmann zu hören sind empörte Besucher
eine Frau ruft
eine andere schämt euch auch hier
verhindert nur eine Glasscheibe
schlimmeres darf Protest wirklich alles
zunächst hat diese junge Generation
wirklich jedes Recht zu protestieren
Götz ali ist ein renommierte Historiker
der 75-Jährige hat sieben Enkel für ihn
war seine damalige 68er wollte ein
Kinderspiel gegen die Probleme von heute
vor einer Woche bin ich um Freiburger
Münster gegangen dass ich sehr gut kenne
die Umweltschäden die dort täglich
stattfinden durch unsere Abgase das ist
viel mehr kunstzerstörung das als diese
symbolischen Aktion was aber konkret für
den Schutz der Kunstwerke tun
museensäulen und wollen keine
hochsicherheitstrakte werden die letzte
Generation hat eine Frage gestellt sie
hat die Frage gestellt was ist mehr wert
Kunst oder Leben und ich glaube man muss
die Frage umdrehen man muss es anders
formulieren man muss sagen Kunst ist
Leben und deswegen muss man mit Kunst
und auch mit Kunst gegen die Klimakrise
angehen das Potsdamer Barberini Museum
ist seit der Attacke vor einer Woche
geschlossen das ist die schlechte
Nachricht die gute ab morgen soll die
Ausstellung verzauberte moderne
wiederzusehen sein mit Monis gereinigten
Bild ohne Kartoffelbrei
die Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Luise Arnsberg von den
Grünen hat ihre Reise nach Katar
abgesagt begründet hat sie ihren
Entschluss damit dass es im Moment nicht
möglich sei offene und kritische
Gespräche über die Menschenrechtslage zu
führen eine Ministerin aber hält an
ihren Reiseplänen Fest der Ausblick auf
die kommende Woche zusammengestellt von
Kai Felix Jochens
[Musik]
am Montag wird Innen- und
Sportministerin Phaser zusammen mit
DFB-Präsident Neuendorf nach Katar
Reisen kurz vor der Fußball-WM wollen
Sie sich ein Bild vor Ort machen das
Gastgeberland seit Jahren in der Kritik
etwa wegen der Situation der
Wanderarbeiter die die Stadien gebaut
haben und generell wegen der
Menschenrechtslage Phaser will von ihren
Eindrücken abhängig machen ob sie die WM
verfolgen wird am Freitag wird
Bundeskanzler Scholz zu seinem
Antrittsbesuch in China erwartet eine
Wirtschaftsdelegation wird den Kanzler
begleiten wie eng in Zukunft die
Beziehungen zu Peking sein sollen in der
Ampel hoch umstritten zuletzt hatte der
chinesische Einstieg im Hamburger Hafen
den regierungszusammenhalt auf die Probe
gestellt Scholz China Besuch ist als
tagesvisite geplant
mehr Zeit wollen sich ab Sonntag die
rund 200 Staaten auf der
UN-Klimakonferenz in Ägypten nehmen Ziel
der zweiwöchigen Beratungen den Kampf
gegen die Erderwärmung voranzutreiben
und den Ausstoß von Emissionen zu
begrenzen die vergangenen sieben Jahre
waren die wärmsten seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen
und in der neuen Woche wird das Wetter
hierzulande nun doch langsam etwas
unbeständiger also herbstlicher morgen
gibt es eine Mischung aus dichten Wolken
und sonnigen Abschnitten örtlich kann
sich auch zäher Nebel halten es bleibt
weitgehend trocken bei 15 bis 21 Grad
dann wird es unbeständiger und windiger
Dienstag noch 14 bis 20 Grad danach
allmählich kühler
und das war es von uns in dieser Woche
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einem
Krimi der im Umfeld des FC Chelsea
spielt der Chelsea Detective und um 0.30
meldet sich Christopher Wehrmann mit
einer heute Express Morgen begrüßen Sie
an diesem Platz Hanna Zimmermann und
Christian Sievers von uns einen schönen
Abend und tschüss
[Musik]